he's the best at covering MMA he has
he's the host of the MMA hour he's Ariel
Helwani who joins us Arielle thanks for
joining us on short notice so can you
get us up to date on what is transpired
over the last 24 hours I got to tell you
thank you so much for having me I hope
you can hear me I'm in a room right now
we're at the weigh-ins and this is the
absolute none yet like and there's no
hyperbole I mean I can't even begin to
tell you what has transpired I mean you
know what already happened between Conor
McGregor and his team at the Barclays
Center yesterday I'm sure you've seen
footage Conor McGregor a team entered
the Barclays Center attacked one of the
buses that were competing on Saturday
night's card threw chairs through a
bunch of equipment epi' were severely
injured bird as a result they were
pulled from the card one of the
champions Rose Noemi Eunice was shaken
up she was on the fence but she will be
fighting tomorrow night and one of the
other fighters who's a member of Conor's
team was involved in the UFC pulled him
as a result of his involvement in the
incident later Friday at around 10:30
Conor McGregor turned himself in
disseminated precinct in Brooklyn New
York he actually just left the 78th
precinct he's on his way to cave County
Courthouse here in Brooklyn and he is
facing two charges a friend of his who's
also an MMA fighter an amateur MMA
fighter is also facing huge heart like
but in the midst of all this Dan about
the year weigh-ins for UFC 223 and
there's a massively important
lightweight title fight that was kind of
supposed to set up
Connors next fight taking place on
Saturday at Barclays but the whole thing
has blown up I don't know if you want me
to get into those details as well but
this is without a doubt the craziest 24
hours in the history of the sport
was any of that scripted setup yesterday
stage absolutely not
well if you're asking me - Conor plan on
going there and and and retaliate as I
was told because his teammate artem
Lubov had an issue with a fighter named
Habib Itamar Goliath who is from
Dagestan on Tuesday Conor saw this
footage they had a run-in and he then
flew from Dublin to come confront Habib
and so if you're asking me yes did he
plan on going there yes if you're asking
me if this is some kind of WWE scripted
by the UFC absolutely not that that is
100% fact no one wanted to get to this
point no one wanted to see Conor
McGregor in handcuffs
including Conor McGregor himself so this
was not scripted as far as his storyline
is concerned did Dana White
like what happened yesterday you know I
got to say I've been a critic of Dana
White's over the past year and a half or
so I feel like he has lost some of this
fire I feel like you know after selling
the company he just wasn't the same guy
he just didn't really have the same
passion that he was known for I think he
has handled this very well over the last
24 hours I think he was kind of left
with no option but to pull low bar from
the card I think he said all the right
things look in the back of his mind I'm
sure at some point if Conor is cleared
and you know this isn't too serious
there is a massive fight to promote here
between hobby band and Conor this would
be a butyl magnate off is the equivalent
in our support of someone like triple G
comes from Dagestan he is he is
supremely popular I mean I can't even
put it into words
he's like a beetle when he walks in the
streets of Dagestan so if they are able
to pull this off and make this fight it
would be without a doubt the the the
highest-grossing pride in the history of
this board and you can make no mistake I
would think they would use this to
promote but right now I don't think
they're happy about any especially
considering the fact that two fighters
were injured and had to be pulled on the
card as a result of glass hitting their
face Arielle thanks for joining us have
a good weekend thank you thank you as
always I appreciate it Ariel Helwani
award-winning journalists covering the
sport there for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]